hace unas horas abrieron las urnas para
las elecciones legislativas en venezuela
se proyecta que el partido socialista
unido de venezuela en el poder
tomara el control de la asamblea
nacional en una jornada en la que el
grueso de la oposición denuncia fraude y
en cambio convoca a una consulta en
línea para rechazar los comicios y
exigir la salida de nicolás maduro
tenemos reporte desde caracas
el presidente de donald sound lideró un
mitin en georgia para impulsar a los dos
candidatos republicanos que buscan
asegurar la mayoría de su partido en el
senado en la segunda vuelta de los
comicios el mandatario insistió en las
infundadas denuncias de fraude en la
elección que le arrebató la victoria
algunos de los algunos en su partido
temen que este discurso sea
contraproducente de cara a la decisiva
votación en ese estado el próximo 5 de
enero
último intento para salir del
estancamiento del break sit
los negociadores británicos y de la
unión europea se reunirán hoy en
bruselas para intentar resolver sus
diferencias y llegar a un acuerdo de
salida del reino unido- del bloque antes
de que finalice el período de transición
previsto para este 31 de diciembre
muy buenos días y bienvenidos a una
nueva emisión de noticias en france 24
los saluda andrés meza muñoz venezuela
celebra hoy elecciones legislativas en
las que se proyecta que el partido del
presidente de nicolás maduro tomará el
control de la asamblea nacional gran
parte de la oposición cataloga estos
comicios como fraude y en cambio convoca
a una consulta en línea para rechazar la
votación y exigir la salida del
mandatario ampliamos esta información
desde caracas donde se encuentra nuestra
corresponsal
herminia fernández herminia muy buenos
días estas elecciones se están
realizando en medio de una pandemia y
sin la presencia de una gran parte de la
oposición que participación se espera en
esta jornada
sí buenos días estamos acá actualmente
en uno de los centros electorales más
grandes de la ciudad que queda en el
centro normalmente son filas largas de
gente esperando para ejercer el voto hoy
hay mucho menos se es pero se cree que
es debido a la pandemia y también a que
la oposición ha llamado a un boicot tal
como lo dijiste antes ha llamado a la
abstención ha llamado a que estas
elecciones la gente no venga a votar
porque dicen que son fraudulentas y
porque dicen que no tuvieran las
suficientes garantías digamos esta
oposición mayoritaria para participar
dentro del proceso electoral en una
visita de france 24 por una zona del
este de la capital los centros de
votación ni siquiera tenían votantes
también es muy temprano en la mañana
para saber cómo va a hacer esta
abstención pero los analistas de algunas
encuestas famosas del país señalan que
puede llegar hasta un 60 por ciento el
día de hoy en línea y cuando se espera
que se conozcan estos resultados
normalmente no hay una hora exacta para
que el gobierno o el consejo nacional
electoral de las cifras de los
resultados de las eléctricas de elección
sin embargo hoy se ha dicho que se
cerraran las urnas a las 6 de la tarde o
hasta que quede el último votante se
espera que las personas vengan no
masivamente que vengan poco a poco por
el tema de la pandemia así que si a las
seis de la tarde cierran legalmente las
urnas como debería ser posiblemente
cerca de las 9 10 de la noche tendría
que haber el resultado de estos 270 y 79
diputados para la nueva asamblea
nacional que se instalará el próximo 5
de enero de 2021 bienvenida muchas
gracias por este reporte desde caracas
nosotros por supuesto estaremos al tanto
de lo que ocurre con esta jornada
electoral en venezuela en nuestros
siguientes informativos y cambiamos de
tema porque esta madrugada murió el ex
presidente de uruguay tabaré vázquez
debido a un cáncer de pulmón que padecía
desde su última administración la muerte
del exmandatario fue confirmada por su
familia se anunció que el velatorio sera
debido a la emergencia provocada por el
cob y 19 vázquez se desempeñó como
presidente de la nación suramericana en
dos oportunidades primero entre 2005 y
2010 y luego entre 2015 y 2020 su
cortejo fúnebre partirá a la una de la
tarde hora uruguaya hacia el cementerio
de la teja donde será sepultado en una
ceremonia
el presidente de eeuu donald trump
visitó el estado de georgia este sábado
donde está en juego el futuro de la
mayoría republicana en el senado esta
concentración es la primera en la que
participa donald trump desde que perdió
las elecciones presidenciales el 3 de
noviembre cuyo resultado sigue sin
reconocer throne viajó para apoyar a los
dos candidatos republicanos al senado e
insistió como siempre sin pruebas y
contra lo que ha confirmado los
resultados en que él sería el ganador de
las elecciones
para su primer mitin desde la elección
presidencial
donald trump eligió a dio ya aquí para
sus partidarios
la derrota fue particularmente difícil
de tragar joe biden quedó primero en
este estado era la primera vez para un
candidato demócrata desde 1992 pero el
presidente en ejercicio sigue siendo
fuerte continúa martillando sin pruebas
que la elección fue amañada
si perdiera sería un perdedor muy amable
si perdiera diría he perdido e iría a
florida y me lo tomaría con calma y
daría la vuelta y diría que he hecho muy
buen trabajo pero nunca puedes aceptar
cuando roban y manipulan
[Música]
los demócratas intentaron robar la
presidencia y lo están haciendo muy bien
alguna vez te has dado cuenta de las
noticias falsas
más de un mes después de las elecciones
georgia sigue en el centro de la batalla
electoral pero esta vez para el senado
aquí ningún candidato a la cámara alta
obtuvo el 3 de noviembre una mayoría
suficiente para ser elegido otra
votación crucial tendrá lugar el 5 de
enero si sus dos candidatos fracasan los
republicanos perderán la mayoría del
senado entonces donald trump busca
movilizar a sus votantes a todo precio
los votantes de georgia determinaron que
partido dirige cada comité redacta cada
legislación controla cada dólar de los
contribuyentes
si los candidatos david verdú y que el
hilo flor ganan los republicanos
permanecerán en la mayoría con 52
escaños frente a 48 demócratas esto
haría difícil la presidencia para joe
biden pero si los demócratas ganan será
un 50-50 en ese caso la vicepresidenta
kamala harris tendrá el voto decisorio
vamos a europa las negociaciones por el
break si se retoman hoy domingo la
conversación de ayer entre el primer
ministro británico boris johnson y la
presidenta de la comisión europea
úrsula von der leyen no resolvió ninguno
de los puntos de fricción la perspectiva
de un break sheet caótico y sin acuerdo
es cada vez más real
bajo presión boris johnson you should
have an der leyen hablaron durante una
hora por teléfono el sábado pero el
primer ministro británico y la
presidenta de la comisión europea no
lograron salir del impase de
negociaciones comerciales por el break
sheet sin embargo ambos añadieron en una
declaración común que se debe seguir con
las negociaciones siguen existiendo
diferencias significativas en torno a
tres cuestiones la competencia del
mecanismo de solución de controversias y
la pesca las dos partes han subrayado
que no habrá ningún acuerdo si no se
resuelven estas cuestiones
y nuestros equipos de negociación deben
realizar un esfuerzo suplementario con
el fin de ver si estas cuestiones pueden
ser resueltas
el jefe de las negociaciones de la
comisión europea
michelle vania y david frost su homólogo
británico tienen previsto reunirse de
nuevo este domingo esta vez en bruselas
apenas dos días después de haber
interrumpido su intensa semana de
negociaciones en londres nosotros
mantenemos la calma como siempre veremos
si todavía hay alguna posibilidad
los europeos querrían concluir un
acuerdo antes del inicio de semana fecha
del voto británico en la cámara de los
comunes que podría bloquear todavía un
poco más las negociaciones durante esta
carrera contrareloj francia por su parte
se muestra inquieta de que la unión
europea pueda dar demasiadas concesiones
a los británicos por temor a hombres y
duros sin acuerdo especialmente en la
cuestión de las aguas territoriales y la
pesca francia ha advertido que no dudará
en utilizar su derecho a veto si el
acuerdo no les resulta convincente
y ahora vamos al espacio dos cápsulas
son noticias hoy después de despegar de
la superficie de la luna el viernes la
sonda china chang es se acopló esta
madrugada con una nave robot que la
esperaba en órbita y le transfirió dos
kilos de material del suelo lunar que
deben llegar a la tierra a mediados de
diciembre y ayer aterrizó con éxito en
australia una pequeña cápsula con
muestras del asteroide riego tomadas por
la misión japonesa hayabusa 2 con estas
imágenes despedimos este informativo en
france 24 quédense con nosotros
[Música]